one thing that they that they tell young
magazine journalists right when you're
starting at is people really love
dinosaurs
so so tonight should be especially fun I
say that because as Tom Hayden who's in
the second row here put it in in his
story in this month's issue they're
really they're probably is in the living
paleontologist who's done more to shape
the way most of us think about dinosaurs
than Jack Horner who's sitting here next
to me so you know fast moving and
warm-blooded that was him
streamlined and leaning forward with the
razor-sharp claws that was him
you know the dinosaur biology that kind
of motivated Jurassic Park and now more
lately the show Terra Nova if you've
seen that is a really in large measure
from Jack's brain so his latest project
is is cracking into the developmental
biology of birds really dinosaurs last
living descendants on earth and and kind
of trying to shift a few molecular
signals around to create or I guess
recreate a living dinosaur here on earth
as we like to say or in the office what
could possibly go wrong so that's mostly
what we're going to talk about tonight
so please help me welcome Jack Horner
so before we talk about evolution and
chickens I want to start with some
basics um can you describe what it is
like to do
paleontology fieldwork how what it is
like to find a dinosaur bone is still
exciting to you it's very exciting
alright well but it's hard to explain
because basically it's really easy I
mean I geologists have have mapped the
world so we know where all the different
age rocks are we know that when we're
working in rock that is 230 million
years old 265 million years old we find
dinosaurs and so because that's where we
find dinosaurs that's where we go look
again so one of the things that in
reading that it's not your last book but
the but but the 2009 book about this
project or something you talk a lot
about that even though a fossil is is a
remineralized bone that there's a lot of
there's sort of parts of bone in place
so it's more like stone but there are
still things that you can learn from it
on a microscopic scale and that's some
of what some what led to this project so
I want if you can talk a little bit
about how you think new technologies and
new techniques are changing and adding
to what you do as a paleontologist well
first first off really there are two
kinds of fossilization I mean it's
something you'd be petrified or it can
be per mineralized and we general I
think everything is petrified but it
isn't petrification is is when one
mineral is replaced by another so most
wood is petrified right so it started
out as carbonate goes to silica
permineralization is different it's it's
actually you have the original bone and
basically the empty spaces have been
filled in with another mineral so the
empty spaces are where the soft tissues
work well we thought that for a long
time that all the soft tissue went away
well you're talking about blood vessels
about organs blood vessels
you know collagen all that stuff we just
assumed went completely it
and it was all those spaces filled with
with with calcite or you know some other
mineral but it turned out that deep
inside of some bones we actually started
one of my former students mary
schweitzer actually took a bone and put
in an acid and and ate away the bone and
lo and behold there was was blood
vessels and she eventually even got
proteins called collagen protein out of
this stuff so since then we've we've
changed our way of actually collecting a
dinosaur I mean we're very careful now
and in fact we built a laboratory a
field
a clean lab you know where you put your
little booties on and all that stuff in
it back of an 18-wheeler trailer so we
could take it to the site because soon
as you get one of these bones out that
actually has this stuff in it it starts
degrading right so we wanted to get to
it as quick as possible and so it's just
incredible but so this is it I want to
hear what it is but this seems like it's
something of a pendulum swing because I
remember when Jurassic Park came out
even the book and before the movie and
the notion was you know you had DNA that
you could use in the blood that the
mosquito had eaten that was trapped in
the amber and then when the science kind
of tried to catch up with that that
science fiction idea it turned out that
well DNA degrades to too much over that
65 million your time span it won't work
but now you're saying well actually
might not be DNA but there are proteins
in there right there yeah we can find we
actually got an NSF grant to extract to
attempt to extract DNA from a t-rex the
year the movie came out that's some good
pub that's that's a good publicist at
work at SF without but we were not
imminent we we did not find any and one
of these days I would guess that we will
find little tiny pieces of DNA but we
won't be able to do anything with it
right so but we are getting proteins and
we're getting quite a bit of it so so
but you know you're not going to use you
know with collagen you can't really make
a dinosaur hard to clone from call
right but now you're talking about doing
what I thought was an athame to what
paleontologists wanted which is you're
doing a essentially a destructive test
on the bone that you found them you're
doing something that's going to break it
right we actually do quite a bit of
destructive I I wouldn't call it we
don't call it destructive at all I mean
in the sense of like obviously you know
disintegrating the throw but just like
you you're taking a piece out of it now
you take this out of it but the thing is
is that you know if you look at a bone I
mean even look at this chicken bone you
know the chickens down I mean it you can
if you're just looking at the skeleton
we're looking at the surface of it and
the surface has a lot of morphological
detail and you can learn a lot of you
can look at muscle scars and you can
learn a lot about you know the
biomechanics of the thing and you can
learn a lot about you know comparative
anatomy by comparing it to something
else but you can't learn about how fast
this animal grew or how old it was when
it died there's no way to determine that
just looking at it like this but if we
cut inside the bone we can learn all I
mean we we can determine with an aunt
with virtually any animal you can
determine what its metabolism was like
you can tell how old it was when it died
I mean there's just and that's where all
the proteins are going to be and it's
where you know it's where the biology of
the animal really is and so so so you
know it's in it's an enhancement as far
as I'm concerned to actually drill a
hole in it is that is that controversial
with your colleagues or with folks in
related fields yeah well it is but it's
if they're starting to realize now that
you know I as we publish more and more
papers of looking inside of bones they
they're realizing that you know they
could be publishing too if they drill
the hole and does it work with old
samples too or does it only stuff yet
still in the ground it works with well I
mean you can't get the kind of I mean
old I realize also is relative you can't
get the beautiful stuff we're getting
you know when we work the way we are but
on the other hand
can look at the bone histology I mean
you can look at the cellular structure
of the bone and you can do that with any
you know in any collection but Museum
you know museum collect museum curators
they like their stuff
and they like you know stuff to look at
and they don't really they don't really
like the fact that we drill holes in
them or cut them sometimes what we do is
we take a whole bone take a whole bone
and break it in two and then we break a
chunk off of it off of that and and then
we mold and cast it and then we can put
the cast back on the bone and so it
looks looks just like did before you
broke it so the surface is still there
you have a exact cast of the broken
piece then you can take that broken
piece of cut it up and right drill it
and destroy it well all right so we've
been talking about sort of that micro
level of detail analysis on fossils and
since you mentioned the chicken skeleton
let's talk a little about the the story
that Tom did I maybe I should just have
you walk through kind of what your punch
list is what are you actually trying to
do well with the chicken embryo well so
you said we age so we so the problem was
that you know we really we wanted to see
if we could recreate a dinosaur and we
were thinking that we could get DNA I
mean we really thought there was some
capability of getting DNA out of a
dinosaur people had tried to get it out
of amber out of an insect like they did
in the dinosaur day you know in the
dinosaur movies but that didn't work and
we couldn't get it out of a dinosaur and
so and with notionally i mean the idea
was going to be so now the cloning has
gotten better maybe you can if you can
get the DNA you can do a clone well you
know if you can get some DNA you ought
to try to do something with it
all right I mean and I guess I mean
maybe I mean how far I want to go down
with Donny toning is something we really
don't know how to Demi we don't have a
cloning we we can clone a sheep right
from a live cell from you know a sheep
but you know taking a piece of DNA
cloning it is where it's you know we're
not there yet right but but we could be
there sometime soon I mean who knows but
but what we discovered was I mean what a
lot of people discovered was the DNA
breaks down and it pretty pretty rapidly
even you know like the mammoth elephant
that they collected out of the ice
doesn't have much DNA with it in the
cro-magnon or whatever the caveman was
that they found didn't have much you
know they're not getting whole pieces of
DNA so other soft tissues still intact
in those cases just not doing it right
so the DNA's you know has a huge
molecule in it and it just breaks down
pretty quick so that just didn't seem to
be the right way to go but the thing is
you know the birds are dinosaurs birds
are dinosaurs so and you know we have
really good evidence of that I mean I
you know you take a bird and you know
they don't they don't look like a
dinosaur at all but but you know they've
got a three-toed foot and they've got
they've got hollow bones and so
dinosaurs it turns out you know really
have all these features as well you know
dinosaurs have hollow bones they have a
three-toed foot they have a wishbone
they have you know they have feathers I
mean they have all they have hard
shelled eggs I mean you really you know
and we just we found a new one we've got
a paper in science I can't tell you
about it but but obviously it's it's
another feed mean it's another feature
that unites birds and dinosaurs and and
it's a cool one but but so so birds are
dinosaurs but I mean look at it you know
it's a chicken and nobody wants to admit
a chicken as a dinosaur I mean that no
it's just then it's not doesn't look
right you know it's got glee I mean it
yeah it stumpy little tail you know I
mean sixth grader looks at this and they
say you know that I'm not gonna I don't
buy it you know I don't like it so and
you know they've got this funny look at
hands which are wings so so it is a
dinosaur though I mean
technically is a dinosaur this is a
theropod dinosaur you know make a
classification it's birds or dinosaurs
so so you start up you don't really have
to make one but the thing is is that you
know you just need to fix it you need
some it needs some modifications how far
along are you
I mean where where does the work stand
well it it's uh it's it's coming along I
mean we we we actually have we have
added a vertebrae or two to the tail
maybe we know how to do that so but
we're not getting as many as we want I
mean we're still there's still something
happening so so with that so you know I
mean just takes time but that is so then
that but that says to me that it's not
just a matter of there's one gene in
there if we could just figure out how to
turn that one gene off I mean like
everything else when we talk about your
next it's gonna be I don't think we've
found that gene oh you think it's still
out there to track down right yeah I'm
not sure exactly you know it's like you
know it's like the creation of these
knockout mice I mean we're trying to
make knockout checkouts our you know
we're silencing some genes see what
happens and and we did manage to get
some things that are unusual do you feel
like chicken embryology and development
is well enough understood that you can
you can do these kind of it's know this
stuff is well enough understood
oh so you're having it we're just we're
playing right well but that's I mean
that's that's a you don't hear that kind
of thinking that often from a
researchers working with kind of whole
organism like live animal biology like
well we're going to just try some stuff
yeah well that's going to try some stuff
I mean that's how most discoveries are
made I mean very few people actually
discover what they're actually after so
so I think I think we'll find some
interesting things
do you see this work is fitting into the
larger context of like you mentioned the
mammoth of like trying to do to bring
back a mammoth using an elephant
surrogate mother or any of them yeah I
mean I I'm sure they'll be able to do
that I mean I don't see any reason why
they wouldn't be able to do that
sometime but you know we have elephants
well mammoths though I mean that that
has no appeal for you well I don't know
it's mammoth elephants at all I mean
dinosaurs are really cool because
they're gone
elephants aren't gone yet assuming that
the tinkering that you are hoping to do
is successful do you think that you then
can learn something about how dinosaurs
works do you have a research program
kind of after that you just want to see
them no I got well I don't I don't know
I mean I really don't know what we're
gonna learn I know we're going to learn
something and and I know we're going to
learn exciting things this whole
business the whole you know
developmental biology evolutionary
developmental biology is you know such a
new field that we just don't know where
it's going to go but but I think that
you know it has some very exciting
possibilities I mean and if you know if
you're looking for an applicable thing
obviously somewhere down the line you
know you can certainly we will have
it'll have some medical application if
that's you know useful but
you know best of all for me and for
Larry right Larry we're going to have a
pet dinosaur and I don't see how
anything could be any better than that
please join me in thanking jack horn